je suis le dernier fils d'une famille de
huit enfants d'auxerre dont la mère
était mère au foyer et le père ouvrier
devait cumuler les emplois pour subvenir
à nos besoins
alors je vais vous raconter comment je
suis passé d'un avenir d'ouvriers à
celui dans des lauréats des bourses
d'études supérieures les plus
prestigieuses au monde
alors moi je viens d'une puce zones
urbaines sensibles
auparavant c'était jupe zones urbaines
prioritaires comme quoi avec le temps ça
s'est pas arrangée alors pour le
préserver cet environnement mon père
disait qu'il n'avait que trois excuse
pour arriver en retard de l'école 3 la
mort éventuellement la mort et au
dernier cas la mort mais moi j'adorais
ça à l'école pour moi c'était comme un
jeu avec des règles où il suffisait
simplement d'avoir des bonnes notes de
de suivre les leçons et tout simplement
de réussir et pendant huit heures par
jour
j'étais plus cet enfant qui venait d'un
milieu modeste dans une zus d'un simple
élèves avec un potentiel il soif
d'apprendre et puis cette sensation
qu'on a d'avoir des bonnes d'être
montrée comme l'exemple à surface était
génial très vite devenu une drogue plus
travailler plus j'avais des bonnes notes
et on prenait en considération ce que je
faisais comme quelqu'un de positif
et puis on a les encouragements on a les
gens qui vont dire est lui lui va y
arriver lui il va s'en sortir on prenait
enfin en considération pour ce que je
faisais et pas d'où je venais ou
qui j'étais le rôle de l'éducation
s'était pas de faire des shows des choix
pour moi même de manière indirecte c'est
de me donner les outils les
connaissances et les moyens d'avoir ses
choix et ensuite de les faire en quelque
sorte finalement l'éducation c'est ce
qui m'a permis de prendre en main mon
destin est de faire mes propres choix
alors arrive les années collège et puis
c'est là que j'ai eu au premier obstacle
puisqu'on m'a ramené à ma condition
sociale en fin de 3e dernier conseil de
classe ont fait les choix des formations
pour le lycée et ma prof principal me
pose la question alors rustine tu vas
faire quoi
ben je dû le faire une seconde générale
c'est ce qui me permet de faire d'avoir
le plus de chance de faire des études
supérieures longue est là me dit mais tu
serais pas mieux à faire un bep ou un c
ap pour elle j'étais le fils d'un
ouvrier non qualifié dans une zus dont
le seul avenir était d'être avec mes
semblables
donc on m'a ramené ma condition sociale
et moi la seule phrase qui m'est venue
en tête s'il veut dire ok tu refuses la
seconde générale au premier de la classe
et les autres qu'est ce qui se passe
mais si je devais être honnête avec moi
même je devrais la remercier parce qu en
fait ça a été un moteur pour moi j'avais
besoin de réussir pour le montrer
qu'elle avait tort donc je devais
réussir coûte que coûte
et quand je suis arrivé c'était la
première être au courant normal c'est là
que je me suis rendu compte que
l'éducation finalement c'était nous
donner les moyens de réussir et de
choisir choisir je m'étais juré que
personne ne choisirait pour moi alors
j'arrive en première et là je vois mon
deuxième obstacle arrivée infiniment
plus puissant que le premier s'était pas
un prof
ce n'est pas une prof c'est un tableau
page 38 table 4 reproduction sociale
bourdieu et là l'expression tel père tel
fils prend tout son sens alors bon dieu
et vous explique
voilà l'année l'ont fort trop production
sociale en france les parents cadres ou
majoritairement les enfants qui plus
tard deviendra aux cadres
même postulat chez les médecins est
encore plus vrai chez les ouvriers alors
je regarde le tableau de plus près je
regarde le la colonne de mon père
ouvrier et là je me rends compte que
j'ai 80 % de chances d'être moi aussi
ouvriers et quand je regarde pour
devenir cadres le constat est encore
plus accablant moins d'une chance sur 20
ça a été une claque immense et
douloureuse
pourquoi parce qu'à la rigueur la prof
de troisième on peut trouver toutes les
excuses du monde allait mal luné on s'en
fout de ce qu'elle pense c'est que son
opinion là on avait une étude
sociologique objective d'un grand
sociologue français pourtant moi j'ai
créé ce contrat scolaire soit un bon
élève a présenté le ce on étudie fort et
tu seras récompensé et là je me suis dit
est ce que finalement c'était pas un
mensonge
est-ce que la proche de troisième elle
allait pas raison à sa mère et c'est là
en fait finalement que j'ai eu de la
chance parce que je vais des prof au
lycée extra ordinaire et extraordinaire
qui avait pour métier une passion et qui
me rassure et qui allait bien au-delà du
programme et et qui m'ont donné
confiance
mais une réelle confiance et m'ont alors
appris que la méritocratie elle existait
vraiment celle-ci croit bois croix de
fer
elle existe et à main ils m'ont même dit
par contre il ne fallait pas que je
l'attendais mais que je la provoc et que
quand même dans méritocratie elle mérite
et c'est là qu'ils m'ont ramené à cette
condition où ils m'ont montré que je
pouvais réussir
très vite alors c'est devenu un moyen de
m'échapper
et dans cette perspective j'ai décidé de
me promettre une seule chose que quoi
qu'il arrive je ferai mes propres choix
alors finalement ce qui s'est passé
après la première c'est que ils m'ont
dit qu'il fallait que je travaille dur
alors j'ai commencé à travailler plus
dur plus fort plus longtemps j'étais
soutenu par mes parents et ma famille
proche
je passais mes mercredi mais samedi
après midi à la bibliothèque
je participer à la vie du lycée je
m'investissais dans les différentes
associations mon quartier et puis on
arrive en terminale on doit faire un
choix décisif
je laissais d'aller voir la conseillère
d'orientation psychologue acaa copsy qui
m'a plus désorientés qu'autre chose ça
lui a valu même le surnom de conseillère
de désorientation et soudure c'est
véridique
elle qui ne comprenez même pas le
fonctionnement d'une classe préparatoire
aux grandes écoles
moi je lui dis je faire une classe
préparatoire aux grandes écoles parce
que je veux développer mon potentiel au
maximum et elle amène des matches c'est
austin c'est vachement dur c'est
compliqué et puis en plus dans deux ans
sera bientôt recommencer je m'étais juré
que personne ne déciderait pour moi
jamais je n'avais pas eu une oreille
attentive
alors j'ai décidé de fermer recherche à
l'onisep tout seul et là encore mes
profs m'ont beaucoup aidé beaucoup
d'entre eux avaient fait une classe
préparatoire et m'ont dit tu sais aussi
dans une classe prépa on cherche des
marathoniens et tu nous a prouvé toutes
ces années que les efforts que tu avais
fourni que tu méritais ma place dans
cette formation d'excellence alors je
décide de postuler à la meilleure
prépare pour normale sup en droit et en
économie la meilleure de france en
maison de façon tu ne seras jamais primé
tenta chance je suis prêt je sus prix
parmi des centaines de candidatures de
toute la france
pour moi c'est une réelle réussite parce
que elle avait cette éco qui disait
travail et d'un ça paye mais on
n'échappe pas non plus à sa condition
sociale pour mes parents et - paris
c'était financièrement impossible et
donc je décide que
finalement j'allais faire des recherches
pour bousculer et cet obstacle financier
je passe alors mais après midi et mes
week end à faire des recherches sur
internet pas à la maison n'avait pas
encore internet à l'époque donc je parte
à la maison de la jeunesse et je faisais
des recherches je tapais sur google
bourse d'études de financer ses études à
paris scor lâche et utiliser toutes les
lans qui existait avec google traduction
s'il vous plaît points comme aider -
tout ce qu'il faut j'étais même devenu
un expert j'étais devenu un expert et
jeu c'est comme ça que j'ai découvert
qu'il existait la philanthropie la
philanthropie éducative des bourses de
fondations privées et je découvre la
bourse françois schneider je fais mes
recherches
j'en parle à l'assistante sociale de mon
lycée qui me dit qui m'encourage à
postuler mais qui me dit de cette manip
qui me dit de manière bienveillante
cette fois ci il y a beaucoup de
candidatures pour peu d'élus
je décide de candidates et j'avais
vraiment rien à perdre
et là j'ai passé un été de stress
j'avais une réponse en août
si j'avais la bourse je partais à paris
je faisais des études supérieures si
j'avais pas la bourse maj rester à
auxerre et c'était un autre avenir qui
était tracée pour moi fin août
je reçois une lettre avec 3500 euros de
la bourse de la fondation françois
schneider ça me permet de payer les
loyers les petites charges mais
finalement ça me permet pas non plus de
vivre à paris alors je vais travailler à
côté quand je voyais mes amis partir à
la bibliothèque le samedi et dimanche
pour réviser d'un mois je faisais des
petits boulots à la fin de la première
année de prépa mes profs ont appris que
je travaillais en plus de la prépa et en
plus de la fac et à l'époque le
proviseur monsieur panthères qui a été
aussi une bonne personne a trouvé que
c'était inadmissible
il a fait alors des pieds et des mains
pour que j'intègre un internat
d'excellence condition nécessaire à la
réussite de mes études c'est à peu près
à la même période que j'ai découvre
l'association fratelli fratelli est une
association qui
par elle et encadre des jeunes étudiants
de milieux modestes à fort potentiel
avec des jeunes professionnels
l'objectif est simple leur donner les
moyens de réussir en leur donnant les le
réseau la confiance et le soutien
nécessaires à la réalisation de leurs
projets c'est donc une sorte de la sorte
de mentorat s'est fait à titre bénévole
et c'est gratuit
les citoyens alors je décide de
candidates et c'est gratuit ah bah ouais
et trois mois plus tard j'ai une réponse
un mail le 3 décembre 2009 on me dit que
je vais avoir pour marraine de certains
alexandra le premier réflexe de la
google
ouais ça fait un peu oui je sais et là
je découvre qu'il ya 2 alexandra la
première c'était une une professeure à
l'université de bourgogne qui avait fait
son doctorat à sciences po a priori
géographiquement parlant ça peut pas
être elle et là je découvre qu'il ya une
deuxième alexandra et quand je vois son
cv eh ben je me dis qu'est encore moins
de chanter elle s'assoit et le pardon
tout nous sépare et où elle avait passé
son bac à henri iv
elle avait fait une prépa à louis le
grand elle avait intégré le escp europe
à la clé trois diplômes en trois ans
dans trois pays différents et avant même
ses 28 ans elle avait déjà travaillé
pour les plus grands cabinets de
consulting internationaux et travaillé
comme conseillère technique auprès du
ministre de l'éducation porte parole du
gouvernement a rien à voir
et c'est là le début d'une relation
extraordinaire une rencontre
merveilleuse qui m'a permis de prendre
conscience de mon potentiel et qui a été
vraiment là pour me soutenir
et puis au bout d'un d'une semaine on
décide de se rencontrer et cinq minutes
avant le début de notre rencontre de
rendez-vous qu'on a des prix elle me
téléphone en dix ans aussi je suis
désolé j'ai beaucoup de travail au
ministère
moi je m'attendais à ce que le dise ciao
bye bye et finalement me dit un peu gêné
parce que ça te dérange pas qu'on se
rend compte directement ministère ballon
c'est avec elle que j'ai eu la béquille
qui me manquait de l'inspiration dont
j'avais besoin
la proximité de l'âge faisait qu'on se
parler d'égal à égal et le meilleur
exemple de ce soutien c'est quand j'ai
postulé pour un programme de la bourse
fulbright j'étais devenu un expert dans
le financement des études supérieures et
je découvre qu'il existe une bourse
fulbright que je ne connaissais
absolument pas absolument pas je fais
mes recherches comme d'habitude
et puis j'en parle à mes profs de prépa
qui nous hisse tout soit tu sais c'est
très prestigieuse très compétitif austin
manière polie de me dire court toujours
mais la différence avec alexandra elle
qui ne connaissait depuis peu a été
finalement simplement positive et
objective et c'est finalement ce que je
recherchais qu'on oublie d'où je viens
qu on oublie d'où j'étais mais qu'on
prenne en considération ce que je
faisais alors elle a pris une feuille de
papier
elle a fait un tableau une colonne
avantages inconvénients
combien ça coûte et qu'est ce que tu
peux les gagner super simple mais il
fallait y penser
dans les inconvénients m 10 8 9 10
feuilles de papier de l'encré
une enveloppe un timbre c'est tout
allez 5 6 euros à tout casser et dont
les avantages une des bourses les plus
prestigieuses et les plus connus au
monde tous frais payés pour étudier
visité les états unis les lieux
emblématiques tels que le congrès
américain l'onu ou même le département
d'état américain dans la colonne
avantage elle met le sait la somme de
cette bourse
plusieurs milliers d'euros argument
implacable puisque objectif alors je
décide de candidater et je fais un
dossier béton l'aide de recommandations
j'en avais 28 mai ont demandé 2 fév et
aya jamais trop d un cv des lettres de
recommandation des essais des bulletins
et bien sûr tout ça dans la langue de
shakespeare
d'ailleurs on me demandait notre niveau
d'anglais et on devait se tester nous
mêmes alexandra m'a gentiment proposé
son aide
à l'époque elle postuler pour harvard
donc ça va l'anglais est dans mon niveau
d'anglais j'avais me faire et elle m'a
dit aussi je comprends pas ton niveau
est excellent je viens de regarder ton
document sans elle je n'aurais jamais pu
me m'estimer au niveau d'anglais est
finalement son soutien son mentorat
c'était aussi de me donner cette clarté
et ce recul que dont j'avais tant besoin
je modifie je mets tout dans une
enveloppe et la donne en main propre
j'économise entendre on est en février
puis en avril
je reçois un joli mail de la commission
franco-américaine d'échangés
universitaires qui me dit que je suis
parmi les présélectionnés que je dois
passer un oral de 20 minutes en anglais
sur un sujet américain je contacte
alexandra je dis que je suis pris elle
est hyper contente limite plus que moi
et finalement je passe un oral qui
durent bien plus longtemps que 20
minutes et dans ma faible expérience
pour moi c'était synonyme d'avoir raté
je sors de l'entretien en me disant que
c'est foutu c'est morges par pas aux
états unis gratuitement et finalement ce
qui s'est passé c'est que on nous a dit
quoi qu'il arrive dans trois semaines
jour pour jour vous avez une réponse si
elle est positive
trois semaines plus tard jour pour jour
j'ai rafraîchit la page de ma boîte mail
trente fois par heure
et jusqu'à 21h on sait jamais aucune
réponse alors je me dis matte avait
raison et puis lundi sera une jolie
lettre de remerciement poli pour les
forts que jamais fourni elle en dit
toujours rien mardi je prends mon
courage à deux mains j'en avais marre
pas professionnel j'appelle le numéro de
téléphone énervé le directrice du
programme
je vais allô bonjour excusez moi de vous
déranger je voulais juste vous demander
si vous aviez une réponse pour la
candidature
excusez-moi de déroger encore une fois
votre nom s'il vous plaît aussi newbie
vous avez perçu 10 mai annonce donc je
n'appellerai pas et je comprends pas
vous avez été pris et là c'était
extraordinaire j'ai crié j'ai crié je
vous jure si j'avais gagné au loto
j'aurais moins crier tout simplement
parce que c'était une nouvelle ouverture
des horizons inespéré j'appelle
alexandra avons même mes parents parce
que c'est elle qui m'avait un peu
conseillé et je la ménage un peu le
suspense pour lui dire si je suis prise
je suis pas pris et finalement je lui
dis que je supprime mais que d'une
certaine manière j'ai hésité aussi
beaucoup parce que je ne réalisais pas
d'avoir été sélectionné par cette bourse
je pensais sincèrement qu'ils s'étaient
trompés est là elle m'a dit une phrase
extraordinaire
elle m'a dit tu sais aussi tu le mérites
et tu sais je vais même te dire quelque
chose d'autre t'es pas plus bêtes que
les gens que je connais hélas cette
phrase elle résolue d'une manière
particulière parce que c'était tel qu'il
l'avait dit
d'un coup elle avait balayé cette proche
de troisième elle avait balayé ce
tableau 4 pages 38
alors ce que je vais vous dire
aujourd'hui c'est que à force de travail
et à force de rencontres d'un avenir de
huitième enfant de parents immigrés du
maroc qui vivaient dans une zus à
auxerre j'ai été un lauréat jean des
bourses qui compte parmi ses anciens des
prix nobel
des hommes et des femmes politiques des
leaders
bref des gens qui étaient dans une case
statistiques dont je ne faisais pas
partie
alors ce que l'éducation m'a permis de
faire est de savoir aujourd'hui c'est
qu'on pouvait être maître de son destin
qu'en jouant le jeu on pouvait créer son
propre avenir
chacun ses manières chacun avec ses
talents et ses goûts et c'est ce que je
voulais vous dire ce soir mon parcours a
été jalonné attend mon parcours n'a été
a été jalonnée par un certain nombre de
rencontres qui m'ont permis d'arriver là
où je suis aujourd'hui que ce soit mes
parents des professeurs motivés et
passionnés des proviseurs inspiré et des
rencontres exceptionnelles à travers
frateli toutes ces personnes m'ont
permis d'arriver aujourd'hui là où je
suis et je voudrais les en remercier du
fond du coeur
alors faisons en sorte d'être une bonne
personne pour l'éducation de quelqu'un
d'autre
leurs vies les nôtres et peut-être
l'éducation n'en sera que meilleur merci
et